foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
the petty Yeti stripes
again
what we knew yesterday from clips that
Patriot hate put out on Steve bannon's
Trader TV News Network
Marjorie Taylor green was going to
introduce I don't know 500 000 articles
of it she's just gonna impeach everyone
ever everyone everyone she's gonna
impeach everyone but George Santos
oh you [__] scumbags oh man Martin
Taylor green yesterday uh there's a
video of her and Jamal Brown uh you
remember Jamal Brown from the clip where
he approached um
Thomas Massey and trying to hold him
accountable in the halls of Congress in
front of everyone about gun reform and
oh my God Jamal Brown he's loud and he's
black and he's a man so it's so scary
when he when he raises his voice these
[__] fascists are terrified of loud
noises I don't know if you noticed that
or not they're [__] terrified of it I
mean it doesn't matter if it's a whistle
if it's if it's if it's a man on a red
bicycle or it's a black congressman who
used to be a teacher who's terrified
that children are going to be murdered
in schools in this country because
Republicans want terrorists to have guns
I mean that's the [__] truth ain't it
the reason why so many people are
terrified that children are getting
slaughtered in schools is because
Republicans want terrorists to have guns
and [__] I'm not even really talking
about foreign terrorists I'm talking
about domestic
white nationalist
so Jamal Brown raising his voice at the
steps of the Capitol Margie Taylor green
is not scary Marjorie
you fork-footed fool
uh at the end of the um the and we're
gonna watch that clip we're gonna watch
a lot of Marjorie Taylor green Clips
today and the reason why it feels like
to me that there's probably more news
dropping here soon that's that's what I
would guess one of the pieces of news
that was made today by Marjory Taylor
Green's second cousin husband friend
brother lover thing Jim Jordan you know
what I'm talking about Jim Jordan of
Ohio Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan uh this morning gives us news in
the press conference he confirms with
his answer that yes in fact the
whistleblowers that they got are being
paid by Trump
and his allies they're being paid
funded
they're paying them money that's right
just giving them money
I wonder I wonder about that Hunter
Biden's laptop huh I wonder if that
Hunter binds laptop it's real no need to
look at the actual corruption over here
friend let's pay attention to the
non-existent laptop of Hunter Biden the
[__] out of here man really and he's
just like yeah sure I'm gonna double
down that we're paying the Whistleblower
he's broke there's a reason why he's
broke
as we watch uh speaking of Jim Jordan
and whistleblowers
as we watch his supposed whistleblower
testified before the Judiciary Committee
and Democrats absolutely shredding The
credibility of this fool and treading
The credibility of the Republicans
because they won't even give the
testimony in the committee to the
[__] Democrats the minority in the
committee uh Daniel Goldman which we
featured yesterday here on the show uh a
brilliant brilliant move for him to run
for Congress I honestly hope Daniel
Goldman stays in Congress for a long
time folks a long time Daniel Goldman
Goldman is God damn good at this uh
Debbie Wasserman Schultz and also a
representative Pickett goes uh
I think I have her name wrong she's the
ranking member from the Virgin Islands
they go after Jim Jordan hard about the
evidence
but he doesn't care he's going to rule
with authoritarian power in the
committee
because he doesn't care about Justice
which it's kind of funny that he's the
that all of a sudden we're surprised
that Jim Jordan's not not
afraid of not receiving Justice oh my
God it's almost like he looked the other
way when his students athletes were
being molested and sexually assaulted
hmm it's almost like you shouldn't put
someone like that in charge of the
Judiciary Committee
but here we are here we are with Maca
Republicans here we are with trumpism in
this country it's a [__] [__] show
they're a bunch of [__] clowns and
they're not hiding and we shouldn't
encourage them to hide yet folks
honestly
not only do they do they set the ball up
on the tee a lot of times they're
swinging the bat for us too
and every [__] time it's a home run
for [__] Common Sense logic and
democracy
to watch these fools like this morning
Marjorie Taylor green any introducing
God knows how many articles of
impeachment
and right afterwards the king Jeffries
wants her UPS wads wads her up and dunks
her in the [__] garbage
with the some of the best messaging you
could get
I'm telling you folks I'm telling you
there's a huge opportunity here for our
country to make a huge wide turn
in 2024.
these people all all of their lives of
damn near caught up with him at this
point they can't hide from the truth
it's obvious that it's all [__]
political theater the entirety of it
they don't believe any of this garbage I
mean to think that the two women who
were supposed to espouse Christian
values in the House of Representatives
by Maga standers Marjorie Taylor green
and Lauren bobert are now getting
divorced don't give me a lecture on
sanctity of marriage [__] you
you either believe this [__] or you
don't and you people don't believe the
[__] that you're trying to force on the
rest of us I don't care if people get
divorced I think a woman or a man or
anyone should have the right to get
divorced for any reason they [__]
want in this country [__] you just like
you should be able to get married to
anyone you [__] want
stay the [__] out of people's lives but
don't be lecturing us about sanctity of
marriage
you [__] vile pieces of trash when
you when you people are getting divorced
and then making excuses
about the sanctity of your marriage get
the [__] out of here with that nonsense
apparently Lauren bobert is having
having an affair this is this is I I
don't know this is allegedly what am I
supposed to do she denies it so of
course I think she's lying
of course any anything these people say
you have to start with it's a lie
if if you're if you're an Ultra Mega
and you say something out loud we start
with that's a lie that's where we start
but apparently Lauren bobert has been
having a legend affair
with a white Christian nationalist
Pastor
who has a family oh how Christian are
you [__] the sanctity of
marriage get the [__] why do you think
we don't want to listen to you
[__] why do you think people
aren't going to church anymore huh
what's wrong with you [__] they
they don't believe you they don't
believe you at all and and this idea
that somehow these people are popular in
this country is [__] dumb I again I
know I'm pounding a drum here over and
over but folks that is the biggest
[__] lie the biggest fraud that
trumpism has ever brought on our country
that it's popular it is not just because
there's thousands of [__] Russian bot
trolls that try to convince us that this
[__] is popular in this country it's not
people are sick and [__] tired of it
especially being told what you can and
can't do from people like Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren bobert
they are the Republican Party include
that with Jim Comer and Jim Jordan these
are the leaders of the Republican party
you think Kevin McCarthy's running that
[__] hell to the [__] no he's not
it's the party Donald Trump born
Margaret Taylor green Matt gatz Jim
Jordan and Jim Comer you queuing on
[__]
that's what it is
so get it straight and let's get our
messaging straight and yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna we're gonna dunk
on Jim Jordan margin Taylor green a lot
today a lot because they they think it's
a great idea
to run some kangaroo committee some
kangaroo [__] Committee in the House of
Representatives and not follow the
[__] rules of the House of
Representatives and then Marjorie Taylor
green thinks it's great to defend defend
George Santos
in an Ethics probe and an expulsion
when it's brought to privilege and
brought to the floor they protect him by
sending it to committee Ethics Committee
which the ethics committees have [__]
joke they tore down the Ethics Committee
just for George Santos himself
to keep him in Congress they need that
[__] vote
they have to have that [__] vote they
can't expel George Santos
they need that fraudster they need that
liar they need that piece of trash in
their in their caucus and in their party
they love criminals folks because they
are
why do you why do you think Marjorie
Taylor green wants to even impeach
people who aren't impeachable
because they're criminals the same way
they want to defund the FBI and the ATF
two of the only agencies that are
standing in the way the last Red Flag
opportunity that this country has
when it comes to guns and people who
shouldn't have them the ATF and the
[__] FBI
in some of these states like the state
of Missouri feds can't even do an
investigation and nor can the state law
enforcement officials take any
assistance from federal authorities
on any investigations that have a gun to
anything to do with the gun
that's right
they're the last backstop that we have
in some of these states to red flags in
Missouri there's [__] pieces of
[__] garbage stood up and cheered
that they would get rid of all red flag
laws giving domestic terrorist domestic
assaulters and foreign terrorists access
to weapons in Missouri you want guns
you're a terrorist come to Missouri you
can get them
and it ain't gonna be long before
Florida Texas and the rest of these
states are all a mirror image of this
Indiana you [__] name the state
which when the Republican Party
not only is projecting their crime and
their frauds
right inside the House of
Representatives
we have them funding and abating and
abetting terrorists
white nationalists otherwise
so when they said in Texas at CPAC a
year ago we are all domestic terrorists
they were correct
absolutely 100 percent full stop
right on the money Marjorie Taylor green
you are a domestic terrorist
and we have to be loud
because they're they're really scared
I mean terrified of loud noises oh my
God
there is a congressman and he was he was
saying facts but he was saying facts
really really loud and he he was like
within 10 feet of me and being loud
Marjorie Taylor green crying in front of
a microphone this morning
talking about Jamal Brown
getting his red up just a bit because
he's a little upset about children being
murdered in schools
he's upset about people losing benefits
because Maca wants to cut the social
safety net
and rip benefits away from people that
they that they are entitled to
retired Social Security Medicare
Medicaid yeah they want to rip it away
from the VA Matt gatz is out there
talking about
abolishing the Veterans Administration
along with his little tirade against the
ATF I don't know what kind of gun
charges that Matt Gantz has
I don't know I'm not sure what kind of
federal gun charges Matt get hands but
apparently he's terrified of the ATF
of finding out some sort of [__]
felony he's done with a gun I don't know
that's got to be my [__] assumption
right
how could that not be your first thought
in your mind when these members of
Congress are talking about abolishing
the alcohol firearm Tobacco and Firearms
agency
talking about getting rid of the
veterans agency because of Health Care
hey Matt Gantz you dumb son of a [__]
the Veterans Administration gives a lot
more benefits to Veterans than just
Health Care dummy why don't you go
[__] look at Jesus Christ don't you
have a goddamn staff
huh don't you have a goddamn staff Matt
gatz that you can go [__] have
someone look this [__] up
before you [__] start talking about
abolishing an Administration an agency
of our government
that make sure that that veterans
receive Health Care education assistance
and housing you dumb [__]
and when when you do when you say these
things without knowing a goddamn thing
about the Veterans Administration not
only do you look dumb as [__] but you
look like you have no not a shred of
empathy towards anyone who served our
country because you don't
and the list goes on and on with these
Mega morons in the house and yeah today
I'm kind of focused on the house
which we should bring our Focus back to
the house as this debt ceiling Fight
Continues that's one of the reasons why
Jamal Brown approached Marjorie Taylor
green said hey knock this [__] off knock
the nonsense off let's get to work let's
do this let's do the [__] work of the
American people what we were sent here
to do
and I think the Republicans are
miscalculating here I really do I mean
come on that's their [__] MO
it seems to be that the administration
the president United States is prepared
the 14th the debt ceiling he's prepared
to do it
and he's not going to take any
ultimatums from Republicans unless they
bring a clean debt ceiling bill so if
they want to continue the debt ceiling
fights for years to come they better
bring a clean debt ceiling bill
that's the way I see it
and the president United States 100
percent if they don't do it in time
should use his executive power
and evoke the 14th Amendment and pay our
[__] bills
that Republicans racked up in
Appropriations in the last [__]
Administration where they cut [__]
taxes for the richest of the rich of the
rich
they bent over the American people
and spank them on the ass with inflation
and everything else yes it was the last
Administration that has put us in the
situation of our debt and deficits
Republicans Kevin McCarthy
more debt was racked up in the four
years under you dumb sons of [__]
than ever before in history
so don't give us the [__] every time
a [__] Democrat has to come in the
office not only do they have to fix the
[__] economy they have to fix the
deficit and debt because you
[__] won't quit bitching about
it because the last time you were in
power you just [__] ran up the credit
card and you blame it on a Democratic
president who has to write checks for
your Appropriations
and then and then you want to threaten
the American people with their economy
it's ours [__] it's our economy not
yours you [__]
you want to threaten us with our economy
that's what you're gonna do and you
think the American people aren't going
to notice who the [__] is to blame here
that's why I say that's why I'm calling
on the president United States to just
14th the debt ceiling altogether [__]
that fight it's unconstitutional it's
worthless it just gives them every
[__] time it gives them a possibility
of holding our [__] country hostage
[__] them they're goddamn domestic
terrorists do not negotiate with them
at all [__] them [__] em [__] em so now
that it's garbage we shouldn't have to
listen to the [__] trash in the House
of Representatives these Maga Trump
Republicans who are running the [__] a a
part of our [__] government [__] them
we don't have to put up with this [__]
and our voices will and should be heard
in 2024. you have the unique opportunity
to engage in your democracy now until
next November
full-on engagement not just at the House
of Representatives level not just at the
presidential level but inside these
states I don't know if you notice but
the South Carolina and North Carolina
Democratic governor vetoed
and a A Woman's Health Care ban because
that's what it is it's a woman's health
care ban they're trying to ban Women's
Health Care forget the word abortion
it's enough of this [__] this is health
care that they're banning
and they overturn it by just enough
votes in North Carolina The veto where
the governor said no you're not going to
ban Women's Health Care in our state
it's time we fight back with our voices
and yeah we gotta get [__] loud and
we got to get our messaging together
and it's time we work in in one Unison
voice no trumpism none [__] you anywhere
in this country I don't give a [__] if
it's at the federal level the state
level the county level or the God damn
City dog catcher no trumpism anywhere
[__] them you take your Fascism and you
stick it straight up your ass
that's what we should be saying that
should be our Unison voice
it's enough of this trash and we should
put the ones that they want out in front
out in front Marjorie Taylor green
Lauren bobert Jim Jordan and Jim Comer
and Donald Trump put them out front in
front of their party apparently
um on a side note here
speaking of Donald Trump being out front
did you hear did you hear that Rhonda
santis is is acting like he's gonna run
this week hahaha
Ron Ron dude I told you I told you weeks
ago that you're you're you're that your
[__] ship sailed man that your window
closed you are used
you are so late on this man you are so
late on this where the [__] have you
been
you are you are not gonna mount a
campaign against Donald Trump you are
[__] buddy don't I mean I want you
Ron listen I want you
to announce I want you to run because I
want Donald Trump to absolutely destroy
you that's what I want because he will
because you're a [__] idiot and
you're a weak piece of [__] you're
you're a
you're a joke Ron you're a joke the only
reason why your Governor is because
somehow Trump convinced boneheads in
Florida that you were good for Florida
and you're obviously horrible for
Florida and not only you're horrible for
Florida the rest of the country
understands that your stupid ass idea on
woke is broke is the dumbest [__]
policy Foundation that anyone has ever
had in the history of ever ever your
grocery stores are empty your
construction sites are empty there's no
trucks on the road you're gonna run out
of [__] food in Florida dummy
and it's because you're a [__] bigot
that's right your bigotry your racism
and your fascism is destroying the State
of Florida and people thought it was
cool at first but trust me when I say
this come into next year when you're
trying to get into primaries and your
state is falling in the [__] apart and
you can't get out of your state to go
run you're done you're finished son you
might as well pack up and [__] leave
now if you're gonna run Ron but if
you're going to announce just resign
because you being Governor is not going
to help you run it's going to be it's
gonna be a [__] anchor
because you're going to want to blame
all the [__] that's gonna happen to
your state on the whoever the [__] comes
in your place
so you can run for president trust man
just trust me when I say this I'm
telling you I know again I'm trying to
help you out if you want to win a
primary if you want to go to the
convention with maybe at least three
delegates
so you can act like you're gonna Mount
some kind of Challenge on the floor so
that way you can Propel yourself to 2028
listen to me when I tell you this
listen to me I know you're like oh what
is some Lefty no what is some dumb
hillbilly Lefty know
that has a podcast he got a shoe that a
few people watch on Twitter I get that
[__] all the time they're like oh my God
you only have eight people watching on
Twitter No One watches this [__] on
Twitter I'm done been through this that
[__] platform of periscope is trash
that's why I'm telling you Elon Musk and
Tucker Carlson trying to come up with
some kind of scheme to have a show on
Twitter is all [__] that Periscope
is [__] trash
anyways back to the point
you're gonna let you're gonna listen
something you should live listen to a
lefty hillbilly you you should I'm
telling you the only chance you got is
to resign as Governor now and run yes I
know I know I know he doesn't have to
resign he changed the rule but he should
he should resign and run I'm I'm trying
to get him to run I know I I know he's
not probably going to but I'm trying to
get him to I'm I've been working on Ron
for the last three months folks to try
to get him to run and he won't do it he
just won't do it I've been telling him
he really missed his opportunity When
Donald Trump was uh was indicted on 34
felonies in the state of New York what
do you want from me what do you want
from me what do you want for me it's not
like my commentary always
you know plays out exactly like I say
it's going to well oh man we got a great
show for you today great show as we do
every single weekday Newton Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch don't forget to subscribe to the
YouTube channel right now you're not
going to want to miss a single episode
but you're not going to want to miss
today's show here's why we got Jess
Piper on
coming at the bottom of the hour and
that's right Jess Piper from Missouri is
coming in in at the bottom of the yard
she's gonna explain what IP reform is
remember this IP reform and how the
Missouri gqp was not able because
they're they're feckless but they're
worthless as well they were not able to
take away the voice of The Missourian
missourians and they were not able to
get IP reform IP reform is horrible
for voters it's horrible for citizens of
states and they're trying their best in
Missouri to pass IP reform and it won't
be long before they try this in other
states trust me if they're successful
they do not want you to have a voice as
a referendum on ballots and their and
their legislation and their legislative
power trust me they don't also follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod today's
Thursday you know what that means bone
end of the week poll comes out this
evening tomorrow is Friday bonehead of
the week you're gonna get to vote you're
gonna get to decide who is the bonehead
of the week on Twitter and YouTube on
the community Tab and then tomorrow me
and my co-host Gabe Sanchez are going to
break down that bonehead of the week
also you can watch us on Facebook did
you know that if you have a Facebook
account you can watch us on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels just go over to
Facebook if you have Facebook account at
the Tony Michaels you can follow us
there also I want to thank everyone this
has been great support and honestly
I I know this sounds weird and I know
that this is really gonna probably upset
the chat a little bit but here's my
thought
is that YouTube you know what
as great as the YouTube chat is should
we and and maybe we should poll the
audience and talk about this for a while
should we just go to Twitch should we
just just go over there instead of
YouTube I'm just asking I'm just asking
I'm just wondering
because I'll I'll tell you that that
twitch actually gives us an opportunity
as as content makers for us to make
money
without costing you a single nickel did
you know that twitch gives us the
opportunity
gives us the opportunity to make money
without costing you a single nickel if
you're a prime subscriber here's how it
works if you're an Amazon Prime
subscriber what you do is you link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account I've got instructions no need to
fret I've got instructions you just go
to the Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com it's like the fourth link
down it says link Amazon and twitch
here's what you do folks if you've got a
Prime account you link your Prime
account in your Twitch account on Amazon
gaming you get one free subscription on
Twitch with your Amazon Prime account
you give us the Tony Michaels podcast at
one free subscription and I get a few
dollars of Jeff Jeff bezos's [__] rocket
money you know what I'm talking it looks
like a penis have you seen it it's a
dildo it's like a Hitachi Vibra have you
seen this thing anyways we get a few
dollars of Jeff bezos's money
when you subscribe to Twitch with your
Amazon Prime account I know it seems
weird because twitch owns our Amazon
owns twitch so it's kind of like Amazon
giving their own money to their own
cells and then they take part of it
because it's like 4.99 they take half of
it and then they take fees so we only
get a couple bucks but the best part is
it doesn't cost you a single nickel if
you're an Amazon Prime subscriber so go
to the Tony michaels.com link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account give us that win free
subscription and it doesn't cost you a
single nickel also don't forget we have
our patreon stuff coming up this weekend
me and Gabe so go to patreon.com D Tony
Michaels and look at that those extras
over there also go to patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez check out all the extras
for what was that his show what was that
over on patreon folks we got a great
guess for you I know you loved the the
last several times she's been on I'm
glad to have her back I can't wait to
ask her about IP reform and what it is
and why it is so important that people
pay attention to this it's it's a very
very good victory that we stopped this
in Missouri but this is going to happen
in other states folks they're not going
to let down I also have a few more
questions for her as the Missouri
legislator is has wrapped up their
session and we're going to get to some
national issues as well so don't go
anywhere right after this break We got
Jess Piper of Missouri we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome well welcome back to the show
ing around through the spring special
guest here before she's an audience
favorite
[Music]
beautiful women that come on this show
they are the favorites of the chat I
don't know exactly you know what I think
it is I think the reason why is because
women are so much better than men
they're so much smarter they know so
many more things this is the truth you
know I believe this Jess Piper thanks
for joining us again I'm so excited to
have you back on the Tony Michaels
podcast I'm so excited to be here thank
you for inviting me back it's always fun
yes well I wanted to talk to you because
you you um the Missouri session closed
obviously
um thank goodness they couldn't destroy
anything else before they came out of
session one of the things was IP reform
and when I saw that they that they lost
their their real big push for this IP
reform it was very exciting and the
reason why Missouri was really doing
this is there's been several referendums
on the ballot that the missourians have
voted for over the last well really the
last decade and they have tried to
overturn those and the Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court Justice in our state
has told them you can't do that that's
not how it works when a referendum
happens that's the voice of the people
that's that's part of the Constitution
you can't do that you you cannot like
what the people of Missouri want which
is the case but you can't change it just
because you don't like it so tell us
what IP reform is tell us what that is
and why it is so important that not only
in Missouri that is blocked but they're
going to try this in all the states and
I know they're they're really pushing uh
in these red states to up the voting age
they're really trying to get rid of
referendums because they don't want the
voice of the people and the reason why
is because they're not the voice of the
people makes sense right they're not
they are the vocal minority even though
they are elected as a super majority in
Missouri IP stands for initiative
petition uh process and it's the process
that we go through to get around what
our lawmakers won't do for us so when we
wanted to fight back for union wages we
beat them back we beat back the right to
work with the initiative petition
process we did the same with Medicaid
expansion we did the same with medical
and recreational we're able to get the
things in Missouri that we want by
putting these things to a ballot and
what they do and you you guys have
probably seen somebody you know taking
signatures collecting signatures
um and you have to have a certain amount
to put something on the ballot and then
that measure has to pass by a simple
majority so what Missouri lawmakers and
other lawmakers like you alluded to in
Ohio and everywhere read across the
country what they want to do is take
away the power of the people and raise
the threshold like maybe 57 which means
that both weed initiatives would have
failed and so we wouldn't have what we
have now if this had gone through and
let me tell you Tony they're saying the
quiet part out loud I saw that
um Senator Cindy O'Loughlin just said
hey we've gotta we've got to get this
because they're going to put abortion on
the ballot and they're going to win if
we don't do this and it's real important
for your audience to to pay attention to
the word reform because in most of our
minds were like reforming is good
reforming is good right so they use this
language to kind of you know confuse
people and we know absolutely that they
will
um use deceptive language on the ballot
to confuse folks well and and they've
done that before in the state of
Missouri and they continue especially
when they get some sort of radical
republican extremist as a secretary of
state that way they can really make the
ballot confu as confusing as possible um
this is all their strategy but even even
with those hurdles even with those
hurdles and even with the unreformed
reform like you said that they want they
still can't stop Missouri Missouri has
done this several times one of the one
of the ways that we use referendums and
one of the things that pissed them off
the most was Medicaid expansion right so
um I don't know this is this is like
going way back right so during during
the Obama years I don't know if anyone
knows this but during the Obama years
Congress at that time reformed our
Health Care system in this country and
really what they reform more than
anything was the health insurance
industry they wanted to do much more
they weren't able to do it at that time
but one of the things that was said in
the ACA the Obamacare as people want to
call it is that if you expand your
Medicaid in your state and you spend x
amount of dollars we will give you more
money that is your money it's yours and
for years Missouri sat back and and
Republicans in Missouri sat back on
their hands and didn't use their power
to make sure that missourians got the
money that was their money it's their
money and they and they refused to let
missourians have access to that money so
finally missourians got tired of this
they used the IP process and they got
Medicaid expansion on the ballot and
they voted it through with flying colors
just like marijuana flying colors
sometimes you don't understand this
because they vote for things that aren't
Republican and then they vote the people
who want to take those things away from
and I know it's confusing it has to do
with affiliation and I would like to
talk to you about that but here's the
thing is that they tried to overturn
that referendum and I think that's where
a lot of this comes from that's the one
they're specifically mad about or is it
others that I'm missing is it that one
specifically because they worked so hard
just they worked so hard to make sure
missourians didn't get the money that
they were entitled to it was their money
for health care and they worked so hard
to deprive them of that that really made
Republicans mad that poor Americans who
needed dollars for healthcare got them
that really pissed them off well and the
point is too it was Federal money we
were giving back Federal money say no
don't send us money we don't want to do
that they were mad about it and in fact
once it passed they they came into the
chamber and they said well they passed
Medicaid expansion but they didn't tell
us to fund it so then they tried to not
fund it right but I'm going to tell you
what they're worried about right now and
why they're pushing IP reform is because
of working because they know that we are
going to put abortion on the ballot and
there is 100 chance that that's going to
pass in Missouri just like it does
influences just like it did in every
state Michigan uh I think Michigan Idaho
I think Kentucky yes and and these
aren't these aren't blue blue blue
States folks right
we know that they're scared and they're
saying the quiet part out loud Cindy
said the same thing it's they're going
to put abortion on the ballot and
they're going to win because they're
they're arm we we um suffer under super
uh majority rule but there's more of us
than there are them there's more of us
who believe that women have the right to
um bodily autonomy and reproductive
freedom and I know lots of conservatives
who think that now you pointed to
something I like to talk about for just
a second and that's the fact that people
like in my part of the world will vote
for progressive ballot agendas and then
vote for Republicans who will undo those
and I will say that last the last cycle
remember 2.5 million missourians didn't
have a Democrat on their ballot so
um a lot of people will turn to us and
say why do you vote against your
self-interest and you're like well we
didn't actually have a candidate who we
couldn't voted for I I talked about this
the other day
um you know I grew up in Miller County
you know where that is in Missouri it's
very rural it's it's part of the county
that is displayed in the Netflix series
Ozark my audience knows that I grew up
at Lake of the Ozarks
um it's that show and we can kind of lay
that aside but that show is sort of
accurate in some ways but it's a very
Republican area and I remember actually
going in
um to general elections and you would
pull a general election ballot because
in Missouri it's in it's an open state
if you don't affiliate you can in
primaries you can pull one ticket or the
other they don't they don't force you to
pull a certain ticket if you're not
affiliated but I would pull a general
ballot and and like almost all the spots
there was only one person that you could
vote for and they were a republican
because there wasn't a Democrat that ran
in the primary so literally what you're
saying is that a lot of these
Republicans that are elected to the
Missouri house or even the Missouri
Senate but more the house than anything
they just have to win a primary yeah
they don't they don't even have to win
an actual election I mean it is an
election but they don't have to win a
general election with the general public
they only have to win a primary inside
their party and their and they're the
seated person what's crazy to me is some
of the craziest of the crazies of the
crazies who get up which I watched the
video the other day
um
and they were advocating that we should
have no red flags no red flag laws in
Missouri they're like we want all
terrorists domestic foreign we want
anyone and everyone to be able to get a
gun and it's wild stuff it's wild stuff
to watch this uh from a floor of a state
like Missouri but this is how it works
these people are saying these things on
house floors because they're not they're
they're not winning elections they're
just the only ones running
right with no opposition you can be as
extremist as you want and here's the
thing to know too so forty percent of
the seats went unopposed that means 66
Republicans walked to Jeff City in 2022
free and clear we just gave them a seat
with no opposition
um but sometimes they do primary each
other right in a primary the most
extreme is the most likely to win
because people more extreme people like
you and I we vote in every primary right
um and we're I'm more often you know I'm
going to vote further left right to get
away from that Center the same thing
happens with the right they go to the
far right and so not only do you not
oppose them but you let them put in the
most extreme candidate and if you think
that extremity is or you know extremism
is going to go away when they get to
Jeff City you got another thing coming
right they were built for this they're
going to do this and they're saying the
quiet part out loud in Jefferson City
every single day of the week and it's
not just our state of Missouri right
this has happened all around the country
you just do such a great job of pointing
it out in Missouri and I know I know
it's not all the internet trolls that
hate you it's these specific uh extreme
members of Congress especially the
fragile white men that you tend to
trigger with I don't know when you say
the truth and you say it out loud it
really triggers them pretty hard but you
are working
um your absolute tail off in Missouri to
get people on the ballot to get
Democrats to run to find these
candidates so I I know you're laying out
this strategy in Missouri and you're and
you're getting out there and you're
you're talking to the people and you're
really working hard to try to get some
folks on the ballot so people have a
choice they got Liberty to choose
between a democrat or a republican not
just the extreme of the extreme or the
extreme so tell me what are you doing in
the state of Missouri and what are you
seeing around the country that can help
other other Democrats and other liberals
and states to say enough of the extreme
far right what let's let's find some
candidates let's give people the
opportunity because I think you're right
I think people do vote based on
affiliation but we're getting to a stage
um in history in our country and some of
these red States especially is that
they're waking up and they're seeing
these extreme things a great example is
the House of Representatives here in
Missouri uh voted to defund all public
libraries all of them and it was going
to affect their constituents libraries
the most not the ones in the in the
liberal blue part of the state right
because the liberal blue part of the
state has high taxes they they believe
in funding libraries on accounting level
um so they do that but that's the rural
areas that suffer the most from
Republican policies it's their
constituents so what what can we do what
can we do all around the country to
point this out not just in Missouri but
in other states where are you finding
success in this so I'm working with blue
Missouri which is an organization to
fund down ballot candidates and this is
what we found out that and I work with
David Pepper who is over in Ohio and
he's written a great book called The
Laboratories of Photography and he talks
about we don't the Republicans figured
out decades ago they didn't have to do
anything at the federal level to chip
away at the Liberties of everyone in
this country they do it at the state
level they you know radicalize AGS and
Secretary of States and then all of
these representatives and they are the
ones who are creating book bans and
abortion bans and defunding libraries
and defunding Roads and hospitals and
all those things so the Republicans
figured it out but it wasn't yesterday
right Tony and it wasn't two years ago
or five years ago they figured it out
decades ago and what's happened is it
worked right they were able to get
scotus they were able to install people
into government positions that would say
um not certify an election right this is
big [__]
um if you can do it at a state level if
you can decertify election at a state
level that's big time and that's what
they're working towards that's actually
what they're working towards so what I'm
working with is I know people like I
spoke the other day and somebody really
wanted to talk about you know Trump and
it it's fine it's fine we need to be
aware of the dangers of him and what's
happening with him but Trump is not
going to impact our state like our
attorney general will uh our attorney
general who wrote an opinion to take
away trans Health Care from children and
adults right now that failed because
he's really bad at his job he is a
republican these are very unserious
people and they really are just like
Eric Schmidt he keeps finding out over
and over again that the courts are not
going to side with these crazy opinions
but the fact of the matter is he wastes
our time he wastes our money you can
look at Michigan and Minnesota and
Wisconsin and they're writing bills to
feed kids they're writing bills to pay
teachers and and to pave roads what is
it in Michigan what does she say big
grit she's like fix the dam roads they
have policies what are we doing here ban
CRT you're like what the hell are you
talking about right make sure any anyone
and everyone can get a gun as if that's
a thing missourians want yeah so we we
really National level is fantastic to
spend some of your time on but if we
could all focus on what's going on at
the state level we'll make even further
inroads and so there's blue Missouri and
blue Ohio and blue Texas and last night
I talked to people who have have
organized blue Tennessee and the whole
point of the matter is to say the Dem
the national Democrats have walked away
from Red States they've put their hands
up and said there's nothing we can do
here there's no point in spending any
money here State parties also look at
districts and go there's no man there's
no you know reason to send them any
money because they can't flip it well
friends
how do we flip something when we don't
compete how do we ever do anything if we
don't do the decades work and it's not
sexy work and I tell you this too Tom
you hear people all the time talk about
we need a Stacy Abrams we need I tell
you about Stacy Abrams she worked for
decades what happened there wasn't
because because you know all of a sudden
two years ago she got in there she put
in the work and people just realized it
at the end when it started making a
difference but she has been working
actively with her people all these time
you know all this time so when we say we
need a Stacey Abrams we do we need Stacy
who was working 15 years ago without the
fame without any of the attention she
did the work well I I can't agree more
because I I've um I've talked about on
the show that the 2022 was did not go
the way of Republicans one of the ways
most importantly uh was the Senate but
one one of the actual backstops to our
democracy that people got out and made
sure that we still had that safety net
from autocracy and fascism is we made
sure that in the state of Pennsylvania
in the state of Michigan Wisconsin and
Arizona that we did not elect
insurrectionists to the governorships
the secretary's estate and the attorney
generals because they literally wanted
to use those executive powers to
overturn elections even if the
legislators in those States wouldn't do
it
um and and we sh and we showed that
there's a huge backstop there that was
one of the biggest losses that that's
the red wave that they really talked
about I mean they wanted to take the
House of Representatives which they
barely did with a vote from uh fraudster
George Santos but really honestly the
one the ones they wanted the most was
Arizona and Pennsylvania there's no
other states that they want to know
other races that they wanted more was
than those two states because they
wanted to be able to overturn those
States uh elections in 2024 because they
know it's coming because we are working
hard and I really think that the
presidential race is almost set in stone
I say it
um and you know and I've been saying it
since January that it's going to be Joe
Biden versus Donald Trump again there's
no there's no question I don't think
there's any kind of you know back and
forth Ron DeSantis apparently is going
to act like he's really running here in
the next week or two and I keep telling
him Ron run run man I want you to
destroy your political career please run
for president of the United States I
don't think he's going to I really don't
but you know but here's the point is
that I think if we can if we can use
um that strategic outrage to engage in
our democracy but talk about it like
you're talking about it because I
believe just like in Kansas just like in
Kentucky like you said with these
referendums in Michigan with these
referendums uh with abortion where
they're trying to take away Women's
Health Care again just like Ron DeSantis
banned Women's Health Care in Florida
the Republicans in in North Carolina
overturned a veto where the governor
vetoed the Banning of women's health
care in North Carolina they overturned
it by just enough votes I don't think
that these things are popular and
because they're not popular we can
actually build a coalition inside these
states and I believe that what you're
saying is true that if we can build
coalitions inside these red States the
Republicans not only will realize that
these states aren't as red as they think
but maybe the Democrats will maybe the
Liberals in this country realize maybe
we shouldn't write off
Tennessee maybe we shouldn't run off
Missouri or Indiana or Kansas or Iowa
these places where people aren't that
aren't that happy about Republican
policies I'm gonna bring in Gabe Sanchez
because I think he's got a question for
you here Jess uh do you have a question
for Jess
hey uh I actually I actually don't have
a question
what I do have what I do have though is
I just want to say uh I want to
reiterate what Jess was just talking
about and say you know you know major
props to to you know the the state level
local level type of movement and
activity that's being done
because
something that you said is you know
people like oh I want to Stacy Abrams
right but it's like it's not an
overnight success story right like you
said and the the same way I would
compare it is to
like an actor right that someone's like
oh my God this person came out of
nowhere and while there are all of a
sudden right they're like where did this
person come from right and and I think
that they were in 20 movies before right
right years of training years of school
years of breaking their back and
auditioning and getting that one break
that you know set them on like the award
kind of path but I think in the same way
right you have people that in and it
can't happen right there are these like
uh outlier stories like oh my God this
person's like an overnight success
because they literally came out of
nowhere but even if you were to look at
someone like you know Justin Jones out
of Tennessee right people like oh my God
where'd he come from he's been there
since he was a teenager right there are
photos of him inside the office trying
to get health care benefits for uh for
for people within Tennessee right so and
that was I don't know I want to say like
seven or eight years ago when he was a
teenager
but the idea that people are like oh my
God we need this person it's you know it
it's not sexy like you said it's hard
work right and and while you could look
at certain you know uh voting blocks and
be like you know what it's not worth it
I literally cannot change your opinion
but in order to change
uh the opinion of those around them or
the generation that comes after them
like we have to put people in place that
will
you know will care for will put policies
in place we'll fight for those rights
right and then again it's going to take
a bit of time to fix a lot of the [__]
that has been undone
but at the same time it's like it's
gonna you know there will be a flip of
the switch there will be a spark that's
set right there will be the moment where
people like oh my God why did we not do
this the whole time and it's like they
have been that's a great point and Jess
you you made the point earlier is that
Republicans did do this they did do this
yeah I remember I'm reminded of an old
saying and it says you can pray for
potatoes but you're gonna need a hoe too
right I mean you're gonna have to work
you can't just pray for potatoes to show
up same way in politics and I knock
doors and I talk to people who weren't
going to vote for me they told me they
weren't going to vote for me but they
knew that I was a person they knew that
I had decent
um you know plans for them so maybe they
didn't vote this time for me but what
about next time or someone who talks
like me or speaks like me or realizes
that Democrats are real people and they
exist in our spaces too and I always
remind my people I mean I'm born in
bread rule I like it my great
grandparents my grandparents all of us
were rural people
they were progressives I mean my great
one of my great grandpas was in the coal
mines and he was organizing for better
wages another one was a farmer who knew
exactly what FDR did for him in rural
communities so it's reminding People of
Our Roots reminding them that their
parents and grandparents weren't
necessarily voting for this sort of
Republican and also realizing too I
don't want to I don't want to obliterate
Republicans and there should be a
balance right we need we have a
two-party system for a reason because
when we when we can weed out the
extremism we can work on bills but right
now we absolutely don't have you know a
lot of folks who aren't extreme you
notice when I talk about Missouri
lawmakers you know there's a handful of
them that I really hit really hard right
because they're they're the extremists I
don't talk about my own representative
my own Republican representative who
beat me I don't talk about him because
he's not an extremist he has a couple of
extreme views that I don't agree with
but in general that's not him he's a
normal guy who went and beat the pants
off me and got to Jeff City right
um and I'm gonna argue with him on
abortion and guns but everything else
he's like he's good on schools you know
it's not it's not all of them but it's
so many of them at this point that we
have to you know pick them apart push
out the extremists and then let's get
back to working and you got you know
this Tony and other people probably know
this too we didn't get hardly anything
done this this uh session the our own
Attorney General Andrew Bailey and our
own Secretary of State are laughing at
their party saying you're the super
majority and you didn't do [__] and the
Democrats are laughing at you and I'm
like yep we are that's hilarious you
have all the power and you still can't
get anything done well and I I think
this is because their ideas are so
unpopular that they have to work so hard
to try to dress them up to make them
look popular is that they're not doing
the work of missourians right they're
spending so much time addressing these
fake issues that aren't real that no one
really gives a [__] about that no one is
concentrated on it doesn't affect
missourians uh as a mass hole and
they're like why are why are you trying
to pass bills that are going to affect
three student athletes in the state what
are you doing you're spending a lot of
time not only trying to push those bills
but you're spending a lot of times
trying to convince us why it's so
important when you could be I don't know
working on like you said trying to
figure out how to fund education try to
figure out how to fund public libraries
how to fix roads in Missouri I mean
these things are important to
missourians and and I think that's
another thing that um is another
component here that I think the more we
engage in our democracy the more people
come around to it because we live in an
age of social media and we live in an
age where you have to work two jobs you
got to work 80 hours a week you gotta
have you gotta have two three four
incomes per household even in Missouri
where the where the the to live is one
of the cheapest places in the country
and people still here in their
households had three or four jobs per
household with just Mom Dad two kids and
it and it and it's hard but I I can't I
can't tell you how frustrating it is
that some of these people still don't
see these issues but I think they're
getting it finally they're finally
getting that why why in the world didn't
we get this and this done I voted for
this person to get this and this done
and they're focusing on transgender
bathrooms like what what are you doing
like why are why are you wasting our
time us the government because we are
the government it's kind of funny these
Republicans run around they say we're
not a democracy we're Republic like you
know a republic is us the people we're
the government you're just representing
us right you know that that's how it
works and that you're only giving away
the game when you say we're not or
democracy we're I mean it is a democracy
but we're not a democracy we're Republic
so what do we do to convince folks out
there that are just normal average folks
that don't really pay attention to
politics because that's that's this
that's the the hard truth here is that
most people aren't paying attention to
politics and they don't want to so how
do we get them how do we wave our hands
around and be loud because they're
really good at being loud I'm really
good at being loud but how do we as as a
coalition as a pro-democracy group of
people stand and just wave our arms and
be as loud as possible so these folks
that aren't paying attention we might
just get a little bitty tread out to
their attention because you do it so
well on social media to get their
attention how do you think we do it how
do you think we accomplished that over
the the next decade or two you tell the
truth you point to who is doing the harm
and then you talk to people you have to
there's something called canvassing and
it's called that for a reason because
it's hard it is difficult you are
reaching out and physically going to all
of these spaces and knocking doors and
talking to people
um but politics have changed and I've
noticed a lot of folks don't like to
talk to politicians at their door they
don't want someone knocking to to talk
about things so social media is
fantastic for this what you're doing
making sure that
um the way we speak is speaking to
regular people the way we talk is just
like we would talk to our friend or
someone we invited into our house that
we don't use super inflammatory language
unless it's pointing out you know that
someone is being super inflammatory but
just being plain spoken given the truth
and saying it over and over and over
again because people can latch onto that
I see folks using my words as and I'm
like Get It Go good job girl keep going
we want to take that message to people
and let them grab it and take it for
themselves and one of those messages is
you know every time a republican says
something about you know a democrat in
the state who's been in charge for 20
years who has been in charge for two
decades you want to talk about bad
school test scores who's in charge you
want to talk about roads who's in charge
so it's always taking it back to the
truth and pointing to the problem and
how can we fix it we can fix it with
balance I don't just like I said I I
don't want to kick out every single
Republican down there but we have to
have balance and right now we have none
and we and that's what we need and folks
need to know that I I think I think
you're absolutely correct on the
messaging and we're going to keep
pounding the drum here and I hope you
come visit us again and again and again
uh I I don't want you to stop business
because the audience loves you and and
you're you you are so right on point uh
and your your aim is direct uh when it
comes to these local issues and that's
the one reason why I love to have you on
is because you are so focused on the
local issues while keeping that National
messaging uh at the Forefront and I
think that's super important so give us
give us a Shameless plug here where can
people find you what what do you want
them to go listen uh for you so I'm on
um Instagram Facebook and and Twitter is
Piper from Missouri you can find me at
Tick Tock at justpipermo I have a
podcast out every week um this week's
has been very controversial oh wow even
better I was talking about Christian
nationalism oh use some of the clips
from our representatives to to say hey
this is a great example and people were
really mad they're like why did you use
their clips and I'm like well I'm a
teacher if I introduce a term I need to
give you an example and these are the
examples you can find me at
heartlandpod.com and then just click on
dirt road Democrat that's great and and
the moderators are putting your link
tree there uh in the chat so uh everyone
go go visit and and go support Jess and
not only that
um and it's just like Dr Rachel
bidikoffer says copy her she's great
with messaging she's excellent
especially on a local level
um it copy and paste it doesn't matter
if you're in a different state and it
Jess can help you figure out how to get
your messaging especially if you're in
one of these red States uh to get it
down because that's how we're going to
win and that's how we're going to beat
this white Christian nationalism and
speaking of that I I'm so disappointed
that we're out of time I'd love to talk
to you about that so please come back
very very soon and we'll talk about
white Christian nationalism friends I
have so many examples oh yes let's do
that let's do that in the next next few
weeks let's have you back and let's talk
about white Christian National and Jess
Piper it's always a pleasure my friend
uh please come back soon and let's let's
do some mocking of the white Christian
nationalists shall we that would be
fantastic everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this break thanks
Jess thanks for joining us
[Music]
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em [__]
em we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
what a great guest
one of the best guests I think
this the chat loves
when we have women on the show
it's almost like
maybe we should have a more often I
don't know
oh Jess Piper she's she's sharp as
attack Gabe Sanchez I I can't tell you
how how good she is at the state great
she's great I though I I do I do want to
disagree on one point she made at the
end she said she didn't want to get rid
of all the Republicans
look
you have to earn it okay and if your
party
is Affiliated or Associated or directly
the cause of everything that has been
removed when it comes to rights uh
against women against minorities
marginalized communities the lgbtq plus
community
I look at that and I say you have done
so much harm that you have to earn your
way back in to those positions I see so
I say I say take them out get them out
and let them earn their spot let them
earn it back right like you know no no
this isn't this isn't oh I'm I'm this is
a right of Meyer I'm like you know this
is this is uh earned or owned or like
this is something I deserve it's like no
no no
it's a privilege and you have to earn it
so you have to be a good boy or a good
girl or whatever your [__] pronouns
are yeah whoa whoa easy on the pronoun
doc you're really good I'm just saying
oh man but take them out remove them
permanently and let them earn their way
back in show them why they deserve to be
in office well there's a whole list of
them that is running through my head of
the ones that we could get rid of I want
I want to clean up a few pieces of
business here a big big step fan on
Twitch says come on Tony do three hours
today I can't do it today is Tony a
little hungover day I'm not hungover
today oh wow I'm not now I may look it
and it is Thursday but if you go back
and look at tapes where I'm not hungover
I kind of look hungover I'm not a
morning person that's why this [__]
show starts at noon Eastern yeah well
that's noon Eastern for you right
correct it's 9 00 a.m for me so I have
to do all of my [__] in the morning I
can't force you to move at to the
correct Coast so you have a better uh
time doing the show
here I'll tell you this much if I was in
I was out Central time or east coast
time I didn't wake up I could go to the
gym and walk my dogs
that I do I could probably film a what
was that before the show so that after
the show I was just editing ah whatever
however because the show starts at 9 00
a.m oh damn I gotta wake up early I
gotta go to the gym are you getting this
are you I gotta do I gotta do the chores
in the morning guys like I'm trying to
you know it's like I'm barely barely
making it we have to what we have to
start at noon Eastern what am I going to
do that's the time slide even if we were
to go to three hours like uh bixfn on
Twitch is is is asking for even if we
were to go to three hours which we want
to do I want to tell the audience me and
Gabe want to do three hours we just have
to make it feasible it is a lot of extra
work to have an extra hour of content I
know it doesn't seem like it but it is
work and not anything right so we have
to justify it and we have to make that
means and I want to point this out man
we've had big support on Twitch like big
support and I and I know it's it doesn't
you know to some big content crease it
doesn't seem like it but just in the
last month uh we monetized our twitch
Channel now we were we were asking
people to use their Prime account to
subscribe to Twitch and it's working
like it's working like you you guys um
subscribing on Twitch now you can follow
for free it doesn't cost a thing and
really if you have a Prime account you
can link the twitch and and you can get
the one free subscription and that
doesn't cost you anything either if you
don't have a Prime account and you want
a sub over there it's like 4.99 but
here's the thing that is making it a lot
easier big Stefan and she's on Twitch
all the time big stuff and right every
single day you're here every single day
we see you we know you're over there on
Twitch and we we paid we try to pay
attention to all the chats rather it's
Facebook YouTube or twitch and we know
you're over there we know you guys love
us over there and the audience is
growing and growing and growing uh I
used to be we'd have like three people
watch us on Twitch we now have upwards
of 40 or 50 people watching us on Twitch
which doesn't seem like a lot but when
you go from three to 50 kind of in a
couple months it's a big goddamn deal
yeah yeah it's also I mean it's also the
reason why we have uh our own our own
patreons right right exactly like we
offer different content but also it's
what keeps us moving and then today I
just sent you the [__] oh my god did
you mention that in the beginning of the
show because I saw some comments about
demonetized on YouTube
did I say no well I said I'm demonetized
I didn't talk about yours I didn't I
woke up this morning without you oh
that's fine I woke up just for context I
woke up this morning saying that our
YouTube channel will Pro even if I get
on this channel on YouTube get it
monetized it'll probably be stripped
away from us almost immediately right
yeah why is because my [__] mouth and
their time that we're doing it's it is a
little visceral it is a little
unflammatory people get offended by what
we say so when when people get highly
offended by what you say like the truth
they report you and you're gonna get
demonetized that's why I asked the
audience if we were to just not
broadcast on YouTube tell YouTube
So yeah so this morning what happened
for context I woke up I got an email
from YouTube and then they said uh you
are no longer eligible for monetization
I just I just got it so literally just
[__] got it I'll tell the audience we
played hide and seek on Gage Channel a
lot of you will remember this several
weeks ago and the one reason why we did
it was number one to get Gabe more
subscribers over on on YouTube for you
guys to realize oh he's got his Channel
That's where what was that is that so we
tried to do that to get you awareness to
his channel but also was to get him
watch hours because you guys watched
this show from like like literally we
have not grown I mean maybe I'm telling
on myself here but on YouTube we have
not grown that many subscribers in the
last month and we have not changed our
views like how many times our episodes
are used
but the watch time has gone up by like
45 or some [__] so meaning that the
people who are watching are watching
more of the show yeah that's all it
means and we don't do a lot of Clips I
don't know if you noticed that but I
like to do the live thing I I you know
Clips
a lot of work and and again that's why I
say three hours three hours is a lot
more work than two it may not seem like
it on the other end but it really is for
us because we got an extra hour of live
time and then we have um extra editing
that we have to do and then if we are
going to cut Clips that's another that's
another five hours a week that has to be
gone through to do Clips
um so it is it is a lot of work it is a
lot of work now now and so people you
know so your monetization so let's go
back yeah and it wasn't really making
that money to begin with but it was
something really great I monetized I can
put my sketches up there you get 15
cents here 15. that's fine you know like
boom however this morning I wake up to
an email from YouTube that's like hey
and I got now I gotta write enough I
gotta make a video appeal and all this
[__] to like prove that I am making
the content I'm making and it's all just
dumb [__] so basically I'm demonetized
so now it's like oh man I really rely on
the patreon but it you know for those of
you who who contribute to either of our
patreons you know again we offer
different content but for those of you
who do support us we are incredibly
grateful but it's twitch and patreon are
like the main ways that we because we
are able to not demonetize this or right
they've never got an extra hour an extra
hour is a lot because that's one less
hour that Tony is not able to do more
content on his show or right on the
patreon and that's one last hour plus
for both of us one one plus hour less
than what I can do for what was that
right and it actually is is more than
that because it's an hour each day right
which is exactly five plus hours
especially week right especially when
you take time of what that means on on
the front end and the back end because
um I I prepare for a two-hour show in
the morning like a lot of people like oh
what do you do you're just drinking
coffee and you're working out I'm I'm
listening to stories I'm watching Clips
I'm trying to find exactly what The
Narrative of today is going to be that's
part of our job here is to set the set
the tone set the narrative that's why
we're on it noon Eastern uh it's because
we're one of the first live shows that
there is as far as the liberal media I'm
not talking about mainstream I'm talking
about liberal media one of the first
ones that are live on the air to give
you first looks and first commentary
live of this stuff uh and narratives and
messaging and try to do it to where you
know we talk about but the owner we talk
about all kinds of things to keep you
entertained to keep you and we talk
about all sorts of things to you know to
kind of lighten the mood but also be
cathartic uh here on the Tony Michaels
podcast so we appreciate everyone no
matter where you watch and I probably
wouldn't not stream to YouTube
um right but yeah it's like you know
it's whatever like I don't know
but now it's one of those things where
it's like
I honestly consider now where I'm like
well why am I putting all of it up there
for everyone to see
when they're not when they don't care
right like I had someone the other day
that was like oh you should do uh this
is old news right or it was like it was
the news it was about the Aging Carol
verdict but it was more of that right
and somebody was like oh you should make
content that's more up to date and it's
like I do but you just don't see it
right away like the people who are my
patreon subscribers like I love you guys
and you guys get it first because
the people who watch on YouTube on its
own like no one's paying me over there
especially now right and it costs money
right so I'm gonna what was that is a
lot of investment right so I'm gonna I'm
gonna spend my time to make content for
the people who do appreciate it and who
do support me right so if someone's like
oh man I know this isn't breaking news
it's like it's not meant to be breaking
news for you man it's just content I
make that I make that content for the
people who support me right and say what
you will but that's just how I feel
right I know I I get it um someone
brings up oh it's uh Julia uh over on
Twitch she said needs emotes they need
emotes I'm around twitch I can't do it
it's all training it's all Tony don't
blame that [__] I've I've given him the
permission to do it up on there are you
serious it won't it will not let me do
it so basically what happens is the only
way that I can do it would be from your
uh your account okay well because you
mean I'll put them in the best I can
here's the thing is that I don't really
and this is why I ask about twitch
versus YouTube and the reason why is
because we really cater our show the
look of it and how it's and how it looks
um to what it would be on YouTube we
don't because a lot of these shows on
Twitch look a lot different than our
show right
um now I don't want to change the look
of our show necessarily but I I would I
would make consider making some changes
if we were gonna really talk about hey
let's let's focus more on Twitch because
that's where we're monetized that's
where people are able to monetarily
support us and for free which is really
cool and you know I'm not always a fan
of Amazon and and really I'm not a fan
of Amazon owning twitch but if there's a
way that you have an Amazon Prime
account and to to support our show
without costing money I think that's
super freaking cool and I think it's
cool that Amazon and twitch do that for
creators because a lot of creators who
have small audiences don't have the
opportunity to do that a lot of times I
mean look at Gabe he just got
monetization YouTube's like [__] [__]
you don't get any more Instagram took
away your monetization Tick Tock doesn't
pay worth of [__] yeah that was super
fun like I used to that another reason
why it's like it's like oh why are you
making content on Instagram it's like
honestly it's more effort and not that I
was getting paid much but on on
Instagram it was like if you got the
views then you at least made money and
then Instagram was like we're gonna stop
doing this whole you get paid for reals
things so it's like well the [__] man
like I'm losing every single source of
income especially you know so it's like
when when doing it I love doing the show
but at the same time it's just like I
gotta pay the bills right well I I know
um Catherine here on Facebook says I
love how real Tony and Gabe are they
bring serious but the funny well and I
mean that's right I I actually encourage
uh and and Gabe knows this like I'm I'm
the same [__] off camera as I am
on I am not I'm not 90 different this is
me being authentic I'm a little extra
sometimes here on the show because I am
I mean I've got to capture your
attention for two hours so I gotta be a
little extra but this is me this is me I
say what I want and how I feel and I'm
not hiding anything this is me being
authentic I encourage Gabe to do the
exact same thing to be authentic I don't
think I've ever told you not to say
something or or Tuesday so every day
every day
don't bring up that you don't know what
butt deodorant is speaking of that uh we
had a we had a little meeting yesterday
it sounds like we are gonna get an
affiliate sponsored possibly with Lumi
we we brought up their commercial like
last week and it dawned on me because
several people in the chat were like we
just went and bought some I'm like well
what the [__] we should we should have
them honestly sponsor so here's the
thing I should so the other day we were
talking and uh
um
we were chatting about uh deodorant my
partner and I were chatting about
deodorant it was something random like
somehow deodorant came up and we were
talking about it and I was like oh yeah
there's this one that I just came across
the other day I've never even heard of
it and
um did she buy some
no no she she hasn't bought any yet she
was interested but what she said was she
goes um she said uh
uh she was like oh this is new one that
I that I've heard about and I was like
oh what's it called I just heard a one
too and she said Lumi and I go yeah yeah
yeah so I gotta I want to wait until we
get this deal and be like hey look
here's this promo code
yeah I'm telling you I'm telling you
that I think I really do think that
we're we're gonna have um because we're
I'm in a back and forth we've asked a
few questions yesterday uh so we're
waiting to hear back from them but we
are emailing the people who handle the
marketing over at Lumi um yeah it looks
like we may get an affiliate sponsor
here's what an affiliate sponsor is more
than a corporate sponsor whoever sponsor
they just give you money for that it is
what it is right right and so it's like
they just give you money for ads and you
just run ads right the nice part about
the affiliate thing that I like and I
think if this Lumi thing works out if it
works out and we when we bring them on I
think a lot of the uh the audience will
like the products uh just by the ads uh
alone because they got great funny ads
um which doesn't speak to the product
but I'm hoping we can get some and try
it out and tell you how we feel about it
but the thing is is that it's an
affiliate sponsor so as long as you guys
use our links and our codes and whatever
they give us so we get credit we'll get
you'll be able to get a product that you
use anyways and then like we'll we'll
get credit for it that you've seen it on
our our show and it just gives us the
opportunity to monetize for a product
that you would buy anyways because most
people buy deodorant I don't know that a
lot of people buy but the owner but I'm
interested in trying it I'm curious he
even makes my ass smell good enough I
see I see a comment I see people
responding to a comment and I'm and
I'm just going to apologize if I say
something that offends you feral uh
feral t16 they said stop whining you
democracy isn't supposed to be easy
I'm a bit upset as to being demonetized
for some BS reason yeah on YouTube right
it isn't easy it's a [__] we literally
we're doing this for a long time
conversation with Jess
and I just pointed out and I said I want
to reiterate what Jess said
they were it's not an overnight success
right people like Stacy Abrams have been
working I made the analogy of actors who
come overnight right this idea that
it no one said it was easy it's a hard
job let me tell you right now right now
Gabe Sanchez this is episode
398. right right
398. yeah so it's almost 400 episodes I
mean we do this show every day and I'm
not I don't think we're whining I'm
bringing up the fact that I mean maybe
some people would see it is whining but
I mean at the same time I'm so sad I
just said [__] YouTube
is the fact that we're both demonetized
on YouTube gonna stop us from making
content every day no it's not going to
uh the only thing I brought up was
somebody talking about me doing breaking
news stories but again I'm writing
editing filming
packaging that whole thing up myself so
uh that's why I was upset because I'm
like I just got monetization to start
building the channel to support myself
in creating you know doing a one-person
show that's what I'm upset about oh it
looks like someone's being sarcastic
okay all right fine see that's the other
thing it's hard it's hard for us to know
we already established it before when
they were like yeah it's hard for us now
but Hey listen we we love all the people
in chat whether you love us or you love
to hate us again we've been through this
uh time and time again and we are gonna
We Are Gonna celebrate episode 400 here
uh very soon it'll be Monday I guess
right yeah it'll be Monday the episode
Patrick says [__] wine it's yours
yeah we can one it is our show [__] you
we will
speaking of whiners speaking of water
did you hear Marjorie Taylor green this
morning yeah absolutely basically
moaning because because Bob Brown is a
little loud about him being intolerant
of intolerance speaking of that I lit
right before the show I literally this
one came out like [__]
like I probably have never written an
episode this fast for what was that I I
just have to put up a couple last like
finishing lines to to the episode but I
literally wrote an episode about this
[__] that we're about to watch yeah
I I misspoke I said Jamal Brown I meant
Bowman
sorry oh yeah yeah I I think that's I
think I think that's what Bailey's
pointing out but Bailey's pointing out
that I miss book I misspoke what am I
I'm I'm so [__] weirded out by this
person's
uh and we can't call him he she anymore
because
um uh Marge Taylor green here he uh is
what do you mean very upset that he's
got approached he's at the podium
complaining I know well it is true it is
true um so here is uh Marjorie Taylor
green this morning she was giving a pro
a press conference and the reason why
Gabe is she's gonna give the artem
articles of peach tree dish
of Joe Biden and everyone else in the
federal government that isn't Maga like
that's literally what she's saying like
I mean the Bulls should have heard me
like oh man you know
how many times has she introduced an
article of impeachment right we know
Lauren bobert introduced an article of
impeachment right an email that says I
want to image that President Trump and
mitchman is much more serious than
articles of the petri dish okay right
yeah yeah way more serious but those are
those are those are handled by the
gazpacho police well it is true it is
true the the imagement is the gazpacho
police the the articles of mpetri dish
is just the um it's just the domestic
terrorists that they claim they are um
here she is complaining about Jamal
Bowman calling her on her [__] and and
oh my God he was he was trying to point
it out I just I just want to say that in
the first like 15 seconds she's like oh
there was I was sworn I didn't have
enough security and and and and then she
literally says you can watch the video
and we are the video oh we're gonna
watch the video I want you to see a
response first and then we'll go see
what it is a lie which it clearly is it
is like why even why even say this wow I
because she's a [__] she's a dumb
[__] let's listen I had to have so much
security there was not enough all on
video everyone can see this yeah but I
will tell you what's on video Yeah is
Jamal Bowman shouting at the time
calling me a horrible net calling me a
white supremacist which I okay so I'm
gonna I want to get this straight I just
want to be clear that she's saying poor
form poor form is to be loud and yell
and scream at someone uh that's poor
form I remember just a little bit ago
there was uh oh what's that thing called
when the president goes to a joint
session and he's like hey the state of
our Union is what whatever and whatever
whatever and wasn't there like two
um people one specifically dressed like
a petty Eddie who was yelling screaming
but it's not it wasn't just one time
right there were two times it seems like
it was it seems like it was yeah there
was one time when when her and you know
Lauren bobert were at least somewhat
friends right and they were like like
[__] wait wait they used to be
friends do you think
maybe at all the reasons why they're
getting divorced have anything to do
with them maybe I don't know I'm just
look I don't want to imagine what type
of this is all speculation
Trump and others but I'm just
well you know that marjor Taylor Green
in this breast conference this morning
alluded to the cocaine sex parties you
know that right no I didn't yes I mean
she doesn't say cocaine sex parties but
I know what party she's talking about oh
okay okay maybe maybe we'll play that
clip let's let's finish the rest of why
she was so terrified of Jamal Bowman
getting a little volume up and and why
loud noises are the fascist Kryptonite
let's listen to it I take great offense
too that's like calling a person of
color the n-word which should never oh
my God
you [__] scumbag okay so she's so
scared that Jamal what was that Jamal
Bowman called her the white supremacist
with a hard R are you kidding me listen
listen to me listen to me when I tell
you this
listen to me if a white person is called
a white supremacist yeah and you were
offended by it they're the you're the
person they're talking to okay yeah yeah
yeah right if you're offended by it and
you're like whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm not
I'm not that kind of supremacist I mean
well here like it's one of those things
where it's like I'm sure obviously
anyone if they're called the white
sponge would like whoa what wait why why
are you calling me that
but if you oh no I've been I've been
called a Nazi you're like oh were you
liberal or a fascist I'm like okay well
that's great go look the word up and
then we'll yeah
naturally and naturally if somebody
called you white supremacist you'll be
like Oh I'm sorry what was that for
right uh but if you get really defensive
and you're like I swear I've never done
or you try to compare white supremacist
to white person to the n-word where the
hard R to a black person like what the
[__] are you shooting does she know and
maybe she doesn't I would guess she
probably does but does she know that
where the the the N word with the hard R
originates from is from um what are
those called white supremacist yeah you
know that she wears every single day I'm
like
do do you know how [__] how dumb are you
well she's pretty [__] dumb listen
right I mean again it gets Dumber as she
goes along here go ahead let's listen
equal to that and that is wrong Jamal
Bowman was down there cursing at me no
he was telling me to get the F out of
there no we didn't he was leading the
mob right now the vehicle I was saying
we have this video and then yeah we have
it on video steps yesterday he was the
one that approached me even CNN reported
that yelling shouting raising his voice
he has aggressive uh his physical
mannerisms are aggressive and he just
recently uh shoved Thomas Massey wow no
he didn't no he didn't no he didn't he
approached Thomas Massey and it was
holding him accountable with right his
his loud voice listen the reason why
Jamal Bowman is so passionate about this
is because Jamal Bowman was a teacher he
was a [__] principal and he keeps
watching these Republicans continuing
and continuing to allow people to have
weapons of or and going to schools and
to murder [__] teachers and children
teachers and children in a in a place in
a school where it is supposed to be safe
when we don't need to fortify our
schools with one door and lock doors and
10-foot fences with razor wire and and
armed guards at every single spot in the
school we don't need to do that we
haven't had to do that in the past the
only difference now is that Republicans
continue to make sure that it's easier
than ever to get access to weapons of
war and use them on children and Jamal
Bowman is [__] pissed off about it
yeah he's [__] pissed he would much
rather you actually fund the education
of children than to fund the prisoning
of children at the school that's what he
wants and he's pissed off about it and
the reason why he's mad is because you
fascists are standing in his way that's
why he's getting a little loud there
marger Marge okay let's again it gets
dumber and I'm going to show you more
clips of this but it gets Dumber here
let's listen
um just outside the house chamber I
think there's a lot of concern about
Jamal Bowman no there's nothing and I am
concerned about I feel threatened by him
he was saying save your party I kept
telling him no save the country yeah the
only way we're going to save the country
is if we get rid of people like you in
the Republican party uh uh what what is
it what is it called it's almost like
it's almost like it's on the tip of
Jamal Bowman's tongue white supremacist
you're a white supremacist but they all
want you in our government she's like oh
he swore at me when I was in the truck
and we had to flee my own little
unsanctioned route oh I now I know what
she's talking about is that the is that
when she went to support the criminal
president of hers that's when she went
to New York
an unsanctioned she thought it would be
rally
exactly and she thought she could play
called out right a liar New Yorkers were
not [__] having it she got heckled oh
you know what you know what's funny
about that you say New Yorkers weren't
having it I I seem to recall where Jamal
Bowman is actually a representative of
it's a Momo it's almost like it's just
like Marjorie Taylor green went
to where Jamal Bowman represents those
people and he was telling Marjorie
Taylor green what his constituents want
out loud right and she was upset I
haven't seen Jamal Bowman go to Georgia
which I actually wouldn't uh uh yeah I
mean if people should go but here's the
thing that would assume that that would
that would assume that marger Taylor
green actually showed up to Georgia to
represent her she would yeah she would
have to go there and represent I mean
the only times that people like George
Santos show up to New York which is
where you know the district three for
him the only time he ever shows up was
honestly the when he showed up to Donald
Trump's arraignment which he also ran
away from because he got [__] heckled
by real New Yorkers and this moment is
just is very telling for a party of
liars so when she says boisterous lies
this lady [__] believes in Jewish
space lasers she says that the Star of
David the golden star that Jewish people
had to wear during the Holocaust she
said oh that's the same thing as vaccine
passports or vaccine mandates the idea
that people were were required for
certain businesses to have that right
well here's the thing here's the thing
it's kind of like the Elon thing we
talked yesterday when they they say
anti-semitic things and then they get
super offended that you point out that
they're saying anti-semitic things right
really it's really [__] weird or or
the idea it's like boister slice this is
the same woman who thought 911 was a
[__] hoax this is the same woman who
thinks that the that the the covid-19
virus is a hoax yet also wants title 42
to protect our border so that migrants
don't give us 19. right like it makes no
[__] sense so I mean are they
supposed to make sense and I'll tell you
you're getting me out in front of the
skis because you have a [__] aneurysm
because because here's the thing is that
there's a clip of this press conference
where they're asking about George Santos
Believe It or Not uh and we'll get to it
let's listen to the rest of this part
here it's not about political parties we
shouldn't care about political parties
we should care about the country because
no matter
Jamal Bowman I don't know what his
political beliefs or I know what mine
are but we both we both sworn
says Representatives xenophobia so I I
am very concerned about I you know what
I I actually this is some this is what
Karen asked [__] right well I but I
usually I like the old Marjorie Taylor
green but the old whiny ass Karen Margie
Taylor green better than this one
honestly you know when she was really
crazy when she would say really crazy
[__] I almost like almost like that
better than this one where she's like
trying to act like she's [__] smart
and she's trying to act like she knows
but the idea that she goes oh oh my God
I don't know what political party he's a
part of uh I don't know let's talk about
the fact he's a former educator
principal he wants to make sure that
children aren't [__] gunned down and
that was even one of the things that he
brought up yesterday in their exchange
on the capital steps and something I did
I tweeted about earlier was like I was
like Jamal Bowman on the capital steps
Within a span of a few minutes was able
to Heckle George Santos and own Margaret
Taylor green and for me I call that a
goddamn BOGO okay because that's what it
is right within minutes he [__] owned
her heckled him and and and the other
thing too is like if you look at the
clip of what happens on the steps
it's completely open it's wide open
right there's enough space there are
reporters there are staffers but
nobody's getting swarmed no one's
swarming there's no need for additional
security uh he wasn't he wasn't calling
her an extremist or white supremacist or
anything like he was just telling her
like AOC actually comes over and I'll
show you that clip here in a minute I'm
gonna go to this one since we brought up
uh George Santos came into the chat here
here's her trying to defend George
Santos this is hilarious and it's only
26 seconds long yes ma'am
last night why was there such
frustration and why did you feel the
need to defend Congressman Santos
uh well first off I never defended
George Santos I was not defending George
Santos what I was saying to the Press
there is you should be at the White
House asking these same questions I
never defended George Santos no one
should report that that would be a lie
don't want to support the thing that I
actually did right that she actually
tweeted she actually tweeted it believe
it or not and the Tweet still exists you
know what's funny you know what's funny
about this is that she actually voted to
send George Santos and they they um we
talked about it yesterday was a
privileged motion on the floor and
really Hakeem Jeffries did such a great
job of sending out Republicans and he
did such a fantastic job because all of
them uh because they took a motion to
not expel George Santos but to refer it
to their unethics committee uh in in the
House of Representatives that now the
Republicans are over and they've
decimated the very the various
that the Republicans gutted and George
Santos was like awesome I like that we
should get it yeah the guy who committed
these crimes as well as 13 felony counts
and he was trying to pass legislation so
he didn't have the only accounts so it's
like of course the guy and because
yesterday in the in the vote like didn't
get the majority to expel him but then
they just got enough votes to forward it
to the Ethics Committee which will most
likely then go to the doj and say here
are the recommendations right well I
mean here's the thing is that yesterday
um they had the opportunity Republicans
had the opportunity to bring the
expulsion of George Santos to the floor
and prove to the country that we're not
going to put up with even someone in our
party not only lying but stealing
[__] government money and then lying
to the House of Representatives about it
and their constituents about it and and
basically making up their entire resume
as a fraud to get elected to congress
we're not going to have that in in our
house and they could have expelled him
easily but they didn't what they voted
to do was on a motion to refer it to the
unethics committee and yes I'm calling
it the unethics committee because it's
run by unethical [__] in the
House of Representatives what do you
want me to do this isn't my fault this
is what is happened in our house
Representatives but uh Marjorie Taylor
green can't um
can't wait to can you give me the the
best clip you can find of the uh a
Bowman um there's a lot of Clips yeah
well there's one there's one where I'm
like this is a great one because it also
has AOC at the end yes and and that and
I want to show that I want to show AOC
at the end because something that she
said is hilarious and and AOC uh didn't
go to break it up AOC went over there uh
to say this just so Marjorie Taylor
green would hear it I almost bet almost
bet and then you'll say hand claps and
and congratulations to AOC for that
because again in the video what people
will see is the fact that he didn't
swear at her he wasn't yelling at her he
wasn't calling our white supremacist
like he was laughing he was mocking the
party and saying clean it up fix it like
you guys are an embarrassment right
right
we don't need to save the Republican
Party look man you kind of do because
you're the reason we have a lot of this
division right now you're the reason
your party is the reason that people
don't have rights don't have care don't
have access to certain things like you
guys are the ones who are trying to
restrict a basic
living for people Jesus man it's like
you you're like oh no you're not a real
human we don't we don't you're the very
same people you have a [__] sign
outside of your office that says that
trans people don't exist there's only
two genders male female and that trans
people
are not real and you're doing it because
the woman the representative who's
across the hall has a trans daughter
like that's how terrible these people
are
that's how [__] disgusting the
Republican party is she's like oh I
don't know what values or what party do
y'all Jamal Bowman's a part of but I
know what my values are yeah [__]
you're sexist against your own [__]
gender right you're you're racist
against anyone who isn't white you are a
bigot you're a xenophobe you are a hate
mongerer you're a conspiracy theorist
you're a lie spreader you're uh you're
not a Christian because you're
definitely cheated on your husband
multiple times and you just got a
divorce and now you're with the right
wing commentator Brian Glenn right
whether or not that was the reason
you're divorced I have no idea I'm not
passing judgment but I will say that for
everything
she's a a race-hating uh uh conspiracy
spreading
bigot white supremacist she's also a
white supremacist yeah and NYC says
[__] I exist and you do exist yes we
see that you're here every single day
and we love having you in the audience
and uh we're we're allies of you because
I believe everyone deserves the Liberty
um just just like I believe that um
Marjorie Taylor green has the Liberty to
hold her bigoted white supremacist view
she can't act on him that's a hate crime
but she can hold those bigoted white
supremacist views
um also Jamal Bowman has the um the
freedom to um actually speak his voice
and push back on Marjorie Taylor green
you know what's funny about this is she
is complaining that Jamal Bowman who is
her colleague and they're having a
conversation in front of a lot of people
and that's what she's afraid of well
it's a swarm of people so many people
she needed she didn't more security oh
scared Jamal Bowman but you what what
is isn't this the same thing when she
went to aoc's office they did the same
thing when she chased
um uh uh David uh David Hogg down the
street in Washington DC yeah why is this
any different why is this any different
why is that any different why is it any
different than her you know you know why
it's different Jamal Bowman is your
colleague she's a congresswoman he's a
congressman they're supposed they're
supposed to debate now rather you like
it on the sidewalk or not that's your
own [__] problem Marjorie Taylor
green that's your own problem Jamal
Bowman isn't casting isn't casting names
at you he isn't being mean he's trying
to get you to debate he's trying to get
you to understand what important issues
are to the American people unless
there's some some frequency that Tony
and I can't hear in this video all right
where Jamal Bowman says a bunch of uh
uh swear words or calls her a white
supremacist or anything like that
other than laughing and just calling out
her party the Republic her to pay
attention to education dummy right he
heard if someone can point it out to me
please because I might be deaf well
let's watch and see if they can point
them
you know parties
[Applause]
you know what's funny about this is is
she's like he was really loud and she
tried her best to get people around here
it didn't work you know how you know how
well that walked out that chant was
almost though it didn't last as long wow
during the little rally the pathetic
little rally as you held outside the
courthouse in Manhattan they tried to
chant USA you know classic [__]
right they chanted it probably four or
five times before everyone's like yes
and then they and then she was like okay
well gotta go bye
when she was like they they rocked the
car and they pushed the truck and we had
to get out of there as soon as we could
this is classic Marjorie Taylor green
the idea
that she's like you can look at the tape
you tell me go back we're looking at it
right now and Robin's right she is
louder than Jamal Bowman in this clip
and he's louder than him in proximity to
the video the person who's holding the
camera is closer to Jamal Bowman and you
can hear her more and you can hear her
and a lot of people are pointing off the
CNN thing that's the other thing it's
like the CNN thing like no more CNN yeah
sure whatever okay all right I don't
know what has to do with this but okay
why the [__] do they think that people
are you you people who desire your
[__] lies and your media and you have
to have your [__] shows on TV that
tell you what to think and to tell you
how to think that's not us we don't give
a [__] I could care less if I woke up
tomorrow at MSNBC is trashed and there's
no more MSNBC I can give a [__] less I
could care [__] less I don't give a
[__] that's not something that that that
[__] melts on me every day when Laura
Ingraham and Tucker Carlson are fired
from Fox News so who's gonna tell you
what to believe who's gonna tell me all
the white Nationals things that I need
to know huh who's gonna tell me those
things he's going to tell me the biggest
things so I can project my white
nationalism all over the country as a
congressman get the [__] out of here we
don't give a [__] if CNN tanks we don't
care MSNBC or foxy we don't care if
these places tank because there's going
to be someone in the place of them and
hopefully they're [__] better than
CNN and Fox News and MSNBC to be quite
honest but let's let's continue the clip
here because I gotta move on to the
house uh Jim Jordan getting stuffed in
trash cans this morning I can't let that
go I honestly is is is Jim Jordan like
Oscar the Grouch well it could you feel
like he's like I love walking in the
garbage don't give our audience ideas I
know there's people out there who make
art and all of a sudden there's going to
be memes of Jim Jordan in the trash can
as Oscar the Grouch I'm just saying like
if we're talking about people in trash
like you think it's Jim Jordan I mean
will I make it later it's possible we'll
see here's the thing though here's the
thing though I don't want to insult
Oscar the Grouch honest
Oscar would be really [__] pissed if
he's like whoa hey look [__] you're
comparing me to Jim Jordan yeah [__]
that piece of trash I feel I feel um
like whenever I make comparisons against
like the Republican party or GOP against
something else there's a part of me that
goes ah man I feel bad for writing that
joke yeah whatever you know like I feel
bad for making the comparison because I
think these people are worse than the
thing I'm comparing them to but I have
to do it to give you everyone a visual
when I'm making the reference exactly
exactly you just have to make the joke
and let's see how Jamal Bowman makes a
complete joke at a Marjorie Taylor green
here and how AOC finishes it up with the
cherry on top watch this
party
[Music]
children supporters
yeah
wait for the ending wait for the ending
save the party
and the reason why she's not worth it
because she's absolutely lying that
Democrats didn't lose children the Trump
Administration kidnapped children from
parents coming across the border to try
to get to try to make sure more parents
didn't come across the border because
they were scared their children would
get kidnapped that's what [__]
happened we know what the [__] happened
we know why Democrats and the Democratic
Administration can't find some of these
children's parents back is because the
Republicans kidnapped them and made it
to where they couldn't find their
parents back because cruelty is the
[__] point Jamal Bowman's like what
about guns she's like border what what
the [__] what the [__] guns and Border
what the [__] are you talking about
those two different things and really
honestly if you're mad about guns coming
across the border from Mexico we're
they're [__] sending them from here
to there because you [__] won't
have any red flag laws won't stop anyone
from buying any guns that they can
possibly get their hands on so [__] you
[__] off you take your [__] your
sewer trash stick it up your ass okay
let's go I'm sorry I just I'm I'm I
gotta get to Jim Jordan I really want to
get to Jim Jordan here I would love to
stay on um the MP3 dish all day long
because she did uh she did introduce
articles of impeachment I'm not gonna
play it because it's ridiculous she's
like impeach fighting and Peach and
beach was it wasn't it my orcas Bill 420
or something like that I saw some
screenshot I'm like I don't know if
you're trying to be funny I mean I don't
think you really believe in marijuana
right she's a [__] speaking of morons
who are [__] this [__] here Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan what the
funniest part this is a press conference
before the hearing there's a lot again
in the back there's a yeah right oh
there's a lot of good Clips I think
we're gonna play a clip or there's a lot
of good clips from that from the uh
judicial on Judiciary Committee today uh
from Jim Jordan be the being the
non-chairman chairman of that committee
because he gets dumped in the trash by
Daniel Goldman on the rules
um which is not surprising that Daniel
Goldman knows the rules better than the
chairman of the committee especially
when it's Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan but here's this [__] this morning
at his press conference admitting that
his whistleblower get this his was
emitting his whistleblowers paid by
Trump and his allies that's right you
heard it The Whistleblower Jim Jordan
has is being paid that's right yep
didn't they just complained last week
about people
hey if you think if you think that the
rules that they apply to Democrats apply
to them you're Miss thinking I remember
Alina Hava going on yes CNN exactly yes
telling them yeah oh no no no no correct
you had right you had uh uh here's the
point the point is is that the rules for
thee not for me baby the rules apply to
thee they don't apply
you can you can buy yeah whistleblowers
for higher it sounds like well listen
you can't you can't pay for uh the legal
the legal team to go against nope
it would be political that would be
political because Republicans are doing
it's not political listen Jim Jordan Jim
Jordan explains it here he explains why
they have to pay this whistleblower
is politicized but do you think it's
appropriate for some of these bookables
including two who will be at your
hearings day to be paid by one of the
former presidents closest advisors
okay so the reporter's asking in case
it's hard to hear because she's not
might she's asking Jim Jordan is it
appropriate is it appropriate for these
two whistleblowers that you're gonna
have in this hearing today
whistleblowers being paid by a trump
Ally cash Patel which you know cash
Patel is paying these
um and these whistleblowers
Donald Trump in December in the Oval
Office I didn't miss him
declassified.com
yeah same one same one same same dude
that's probably going to serve a nice
Federal sentence that's yeah yeah more
than likely okay let's see what Jim
Jordan has to say about cash Patel
paying literally paying paying
whistleblowers two of them that are
gonna appear where we're gonna see some
testimony for let's listen
they got a family how are they supposed
to feed their family 400 and get a
[__] job pull yourself up by the
bootstraps [__] what what when did
Republicans all of a sudden think that
people shouldn't have jobs shouldn't
shouldn't go work hard work hard and
earn their keeping this wait wait wait
wait wait so now they think
whistleblowers should be able to just
live off what that's right no no that
sounds like it sounds like political
operatives listen they think political
operators should be able to pay
whistleblowers so that they can blow the
whistle do whatever they want see what
they want it sounds like they want to
put whistleblowers on government
assistance wow easy easy they I don't
know they mean it sounds like well they
mean they mean they're whistleblowers
that's what they mean right right but
they want to they want to give them a
stipend they want to give them an amount
of money well I mean they need these
whistleblowers to say and do the things
they need them to do they're right Gabe
said they get mad at people who God
forbid had to survive on sixteen hundred
dollars from the [__] pandemic and
well and and then and and now and now
listen hey that's a natural bride Gabe
Sanchez that's an actual bribe when the
government makes sure that they can crop
up the economy by giving people uh
monthly income and checks in the form of
child tax credits and kovacic that's
bribery okay this is also the same party
that doesn't want to give people certain
uh no no right they want to cut those
things of course those people are lazy
those people are lazy game changers
those people don't want to get jobs
there should be work you know what maybe
that's what Republicans should put in
their bill that whistleblowers have work
requirements when cash Mattel and the
Trump campaign is paying whistleblowers
there should be work requirements for
those bribery payments I'm just saying
let's say so does that mean that we
should have been paying people like
reality winner well um possibly let's
listen what Jim Jordan let's see how oh
God damn it hold on if they're gonna
then say Donald Trump is a whistleblower
because he took those documents and that
he deserves to get paid I'm gonna be
[__] livid but I
if that's the argument they come up with
I won't be Donald Trump was a
whistleblower and that's why he actually
had the documents and we deserve him to
give him money
yeah well let's see let's see what he
says 50 days oh my God the FBI has kept
these uh has kept Mr O'Boyle in in limbo
where he can't work without pay he's got
four kids he was selected to come to
this special uh unit they were forming
here in Virginia he moves his family and
the day he gets here the day he gets
here they say hey we're suspending your
clearance and they won't let him get
access to his furniture his clothes and
he's got a oh by the way this is what
whining actually sounds like yeah anyway
I just I'll point that out remember this
is what whining actually sounds like
Okay so let's go to the hearing because
it is weird it is weird that we found
out this morning that Jim Jordan is
admitting that yeah we're playing
whistleblowers of course we are how
would we keep them to live in their
families I mean of course we're bribing
them and of course cash Patel the close
Ally of Donald Trump who they're trying
to keep each other out of prison is
bribing them um here is it where the
[__] why is this hearing [__]
oh man there's a lot of Clips I'm
looking for eclipse of this hearing
um there's a couple that I thought I
retweeted them but
I must not have I was watching a lot
there was one with uh Matt Gates I think
Aaron well [__] man I don't and well
that might be a good one um there's a
couple more this morning though there's
one of Daniel Goldman pointing out the
rules to Jim Jordan and Jim Jordan
absolutely is a [__] oh here's one of
Connolly that should be uh interesting
let's see uh what else do we have oh uh
Plaskett and represented Plaskett she's
uh she's a real she's a great voice for
I don't know like truth and
reasonability out washerman Schultz
there's another good one uh that I
believe this one here is the one of
Daniel Goldman
um yes I believe this is it this is Jim
Jordan getting stuffed in the garbage
about rules in his own goddamn committee
again he's a chairman you think he would
know the rules of Congress and his
committee about the rules
on the border state your point of order
the point of order is why does rule 11
Clause 2 subsection e1a not apply to
this subcommittee you see Jim Jordan
slouch back in his chair there he's like
oh [__] Daniel Goldman knowing the law
that son of a [__] knowing the rules of
Congress what the [__] is this damn it
God damn it how how do they elect such
serious people in their body how do they
elect such serious people in their
caucus that I can't get away with this
[__] lying here's what's happening is
Jim Jordan is trying to keep the The
Whistleblower evidence and whistleblower
testimony away from Democrats in the
committee and the reason why Jim Jordan
is doing this is because of the reason
why you think it is is because the
testimony is not a good narrative for
republicans and their aim it's not it's
going to destroy their aim and their
message that someone's weaponizing
government when it's actually clearly
them it is clearly them it is
weaponizing government against the truth
and they're trying to spread false
narratives and they're trying to do it
with this guy this [__] witness today
this whistleblower who's being paid by
cash Patel but let's continue here and
show how Jim Jordan is really not only
is he unserious and not only is he not
about Law and Order Injustice because he
always looks the other way he even when
his own students are being um less than
sexually assaulted Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan steps on another rate
here with the rules committee I can read
for you each committee shall keep a
complete record of all Committee Action
which shall include in the case of a
meeting or hearing transcript a
substantially verbatim account of
remarks actually made during the
proceedings subject only to some
technical things such records shall be
the property of the house and each
member delegate and the resident
commissioner shall have access there too
why does that not apply where is The
Whistleblower exception in the rules of
Congress
above the committee to decide so um
again Daniel Goldman uh brilliantly I
don't know pointing out what how it
actually works it really isn't that hard
I mean Daniel Goldman is a very serious
individual he's very smart he knows the
rules of Congress better than uh Jim
Jordan obviously
um but when he actually brings this [__]
up it is hilarious to watch Jim Jordan
try to say no I'm the dictator I'm the
king I'm the authoritarian like they're
saying it out loud watch what he does
here it's it's [__] it's like well
duh of course Jordan thinks that he's
the king of all Kings and he gets to do
whatever he wants he's a fascist watch
we have the rules of the house we have
the Whistleblower testimony the
whistlebra does not wish that to be made
available to the Democrats at this
whistleblower doesn't make committee
rules Mr Lynch
Mr Lynch is recognized for five minutes
of questioning
Mr chairman is is the ruling of the
chair always unquestioned or do we have
a vote on on how some of these issues
point of border and there's something I
just did say the product point of order
Jim Jordan is very frustrated yeah
he's like
like we talked about the past few days
about how Ron DeSantis and uh
and Mike Pence are total like [__]
Androids are like and I am going to do
this human emotion number three like the
idea that Jim Jordan I was like
you're stopped being so mean like Jim
Jordan is [__]
just absolutely losing it it's not going
his way and he don't mind just because
he was the chair that he would [__]
be able to own this well and that's the
beauty of Daniel Goldman knowing uh the
[__] rules he's like what are you
gonna do you're gonna you're gonna
[__] do it let's do it man and of
course of course Jim Jordan tries to
move on just double down and move on but
uh Debbie Wasserman Schultz of Florida
does not does not let uh Jim Jordan get
away with this Mr friend uh who is one
of their paid bribe whistleblowers uh by
cash Patel and probably Trump himself uh
washerman Schultz points out why he's
not actually a whistleblower and why is
Clarence was revoked because he should
have had it revoked listen to this this
is their witness this is their
whistleblower the one that's being paid
by cash Mattel wait is it is The
Whistleblower also the person that's in
the photo behind her
um I don't know I haven't I haven't
watched these videos so I don't know Mr
friend who is sitting as a witness is
The Whistleblower he's the one he's one
of the ones being paid by cash Patel
let's listen to washerman Schultz rip
him to shreds wad him up and dunk him in
the [__] garbage Tom you also claim
that your top secret secret security
clearance was improperly revoked he had
an independent investigation concluded
that you demonstrated a number of
security concerns
you refused to execute a court ordered
arrest warrant when you downloaded
documents from intelligence to an
unauthorized removable platform could be
your unauthorized recording of executive
management oops I'm sure you know
violates Florida law yep along with your
unsanctioned interviews with Sputnik
news established by the Russian
government in 2014
's cronies I'm a gentleman Inspire who
is weaponizing government
now if you were unclear if you were
unclear and you were like whoa Tony you
cash Patel is paying we're paying people
to be whistleblowers and then come
testify before the weaponization
committee and Jim I don't report set
crime Jordan to get their narrative into
the space and Democrats not having the
pre-testimony to rebuttal this and the
reason why is because this person has
been Breaking Florida law and giving
yeah taking classified documents taking
privileged documents on a flash drive
and giving unsanctioned interviews to
Sputnik oh a Russian TV huh I wonder I
wonder I wonder if the payment of this
whistleblower to say this [__] stuff
to bribe this person is the worst that
it possibly can get and the answer is
absolutely not it is Republicans it is
going to get worse and worse and worse
for them because they aren't [__]
ridiculous I just want to point out uh
uh Torchy coquino says on Twitch dude
this is the best rake stepping session
so far I mean God damn it's a Roderick
says five rake moments
I mean it's dude it um hey but it's
gonna get worse folks this is this is
the best they got so far this is the
best they got so far well they're like
oh no
think think about what the informant and
The Whistleblower is actually saying
think about it yeah think about what
they're actually saying and think about
if what they're actually saying which is
all [__] is worse than what they're
doing to get them to say it and who is
saying it this is really stupid [__] and
and I told you the other day that Durham
the Durham report was a total flop total
flop just like the hunter Baden Hunter
Biden Revelations and all that [__] oh
that Jim Comer had a press conference
about guess what today this is all
[__] rake stepping again face plants
but here's the thing is they're gonna
keep doing this and the Durham the
Durham testimony is going to be the next
huge rake stepping we're gonna have
great [__] footage great footage
fantastic footage
of Daniel Goldman questioning
questioning John Durham and let me tell
you something John Durham's not an idiot
he's not but in comparison to Daniel
Goldman he's totally [__] yeah he's
totally [__] and there's I I can't see
any way why Republicans would want that
want that piece of evidence to exist
where Daniel Goldman absolutely
undresses Durham but that's the next
great stepping today it's this tomorrow
it's that uh and there'll be more and
more of it because they're Republicans
because they're Maga because we are at
the intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and the other thing Moran we're at
the end of the show God damn we do need
three hours don't we this is why we want
three hours it truly is why we want
three yards oh my God I did not I just
want to say I did not see those clips
and now I'm like God damn it there's
another [__] one Nazi do you I did
not see that clip at all like but it I
feel like I get I feel like I'd be like
hey guys here's the clip what was that
okay here's a quick summary and then be
like just watch these clips and that's
just the episode that's just like look
look I don't I don't know you didn't
make any rights here washerman
good job of explaining why why he
shouldn't even be a witness uh in this
case but you know this is how it goes
this is how it goes and what you should
do to stay on top of this because a lot
of uh I mean this clip let me see let me
make sure I know I don't want to speak
out of turn here that clip only has a
hundred thousand views
should have gazillions of views but
that's why that's why you come here
every single weekday because I stay on
top of it I was watching these clips all
morning wow I was making breakfast and
everything yeah you tried and I found it
there we go that's it that's the one
that's the one I'm gonna show you if you
think paying and bribing The
Whistleblower or something why wait till
you uh hold my beer Deborah Debbie
Wasserman Schultz says and don't forget
you're going to want to watch this
content because you're going to want to
stay on top of this every single weekday
so don't forget to subscribe to the
Johnny Michael's podcast also go to the
community tab Tonight on YouTube Gabe
because yeah after you posted on Twitter
I'll post it on YouTube maybe if I'm not
napping too late
uh last week so you're gonna get to vote
you're gonna get to vote for bonehead of
the week you vote you decide on YouTube
on the community tab or on Twitter at
Tony Michael's pond so don't forget to
follow us there for bone of the week
tomorrow's Friday and then the second
hour we break down the bone ahead of the
week also download every single episode
on Apple Spotify and Google if you still
have Facebook you can watch it over
there at the Tony Michaels go follow us
at the Tony Michaels on Facebook you can
find us over there also I want to thank
let's let's see if we can get a check in
here oh my gosh we got more followers on
Twitch today we got more
subscribers today with twitch you guys
are you guys are the best if you do have
an Amazon Prime account please link it
to your Twitch account give us that one
free subscription you get with your
Prime account we get a couple dollars
and it doesn't cost you a single nickel
if you're a prime user and if you want
to know how to do that just go to the
Tony michaels.com the link is there it's
like the fourth one it says link Amazon
and twitch just go to the Tony
michaels.com also check out my patreon
while you're there for any extra content
and while you're on patreon don't forget
to visit Gabe Sanchez's patreon for what
was that show yeah it'll be uh like I
said there'll be a new episode that
comes out today it's going to be about
Margaret Taylor green and her [__]
[__] well there's a lot of [__]
and she's gonna have more [__] today
tomorrow the next day there's going to
be plenty of what was that episodes on
marjor Taylor because she's a [__]
bonehead she's a [__] bonehead and to
keep up with the bone ends again every
single weekday right here two full hours
YouTube Twitter twitch Facebook same
time same place tomorrow it's gonna be
Friday bonus the week Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon